well a las vegas woman searching for
answers this afternoon after discovering
the tree and a memorial plaque in honor
of her baby gone from a park in the lone
mountain area she spoke with with
victoria sahoo joins us live in studio
this afternoon with the next steps
victoria this mom is left devastated
because her baby was cremated and the
only place she would go to honor her
baby has suddenly disappeared and she
says the toughest part about all of this
is that no one called to give her a
warning before she found out herself
when visiting the area this weekend
this is where it was
it was like crazy what was once a
beautifully decorated plaque under a big
tree at mountain crest park is now empty
it almost felt like
something else was snatched for me again
the process of losing the baby that's an
unexpected
process on friday june 10 ambrosia crumb
came to the park to decorate the plaque
on what would have been her daughter
ava's fourth birthday only to find the
tree cut down in the plaque gone i
didn't have to find out like that on
that day i really i'm kind of
disappointed no one from the parks and
recreation department had called crump
so she doesn't know what happened or why
the memorial site was taken down after
four years vegas is hot trees die
people steal things those things happen
but i do think it could have been
handled a little differently this tree
was sentimental to crump and her family
when baby ava died they held a balloon
release near this area one balloon kind
of stayed and stuck
and we noticed it because we're like oh
that's kind of weird why is this balloon
stuck in this particular tree for so
long we kind of watched it and it
actually didn't leave until we left and
we're like well maybe she was hanging
out with us here by monday afternoon 8
news now has learned the tree was among
seven others cut down because it died
the company in charge of maintenance for
the park is called real property
management has not answered any of my
calls but they told the county they cut
down the tree a few months ago they
claimed they were backlogged which is
why they don't they didn't reach out to
the family the county says real property
management is now working with the
family to find a new memorial tree and
that baby ava's plaque has now been
recovered kirsten thank you victoria